premier jeu du studio niveau les acteurs
majeurs politique dans un passé récent
parlait de l'importance de développer
les relations entre l'europe de la
russie il indiquait le fait qu' il
disait que la réussite d'une partie de
l'europe et géographiquement
ce qui est important au centre culturel
de terme
en fait c'est une seule civilisation les
les dirigeants français parlaient de
d'un espace unique entre 2,2 liban
jusqu'à l'oural et moi je disais la même
chose jusqu'à le niveau stocks
personnellement moi j'ai entendu la
position de l'ancien dirigeant
l'ancien chancelier allemand helmut kohl
il disait que si on veut préserver
l'europe et le conserver le statut de
centre du monde
à l'avenir c'est à dire que tout les
tous les problèmes d'évolution de la
communauté internationale est bien
évidemment le l'europe occidentale et là
aussi doivent être ensemble et c'est
difficile de pas être d'accord c'est une
position que je partage aujourd'hui la
situation n'est pas normal c'est clair
l'agenda est quand même un peu délicat
aujourd'hui est donc l'intérêt de la
russie comme des pays occidentaux
je dis bon c'est sûr que la pandémie a
joué un rôle ici négatif le volume des
échanges avec
l'union européenne qui est un de nos
partenaires essentiels privilégiées la
question se pose aujourd'hui pour
retrouver donc ce volume des échanges
perdurent et maintenir ces échanges les
augmenter les renforcer là l'europe et
la russie sur ce plan au point de vue
économique sont des partenaires tout à
fait naturel du point de vue des
échanges et de développement de la
science des échanges culturels et que la
russie était fait partie du patrimoine
culturel de la russie on va ajouter
quand même que la russie comme plus
grande
territorialement que l'europe mais il ya
aussi un potentiel humain ici et je vais
pas énumérer tous les points positifs
ici et ce sont tous ces points qui sont
importants pour la chimie ce qui est
important ici c'est qu'il faut procéder
un dialogue direct entre nous se
débarrasser des phobies du passé ne pas
s'appuyer sur les pas se servir des
processus politiques internes qui a
hérité des siècles précédents mais
regarder ensemble l'avenir ici nous
savons nous redresser au-dessus de ses
phobies
à ce moment là effectivement nous sommes
à une étape positive de nos échanges et
nous le voulons nous le souhaitons nous
y sommes prêts
l'amour n'est pas possible si s'il n'est
pas partagée s'il n'est que dans un sens
il faut la réciprocité